scheitelhöhe 2009 10 ist der name einer
einwöchigen miliz übung zum schutz
kritischer infrastruktur in tirol
angesichts der doch geringfügig
materielle ausstattung der beliebt ist
das eine eine große leistung die sehr
anerkennenswert ist und ich kann nur
sagen allen eingesetzten soldaten
beim schutz wichtiger infrastruktur sind
nicht nur strom wasser und andere
sensible bereiche gemeint besonders im
fokus dieser übung steht die transalpine
ölleitung kurz teil genannt da denkt man
auf geordnete das hier natürlich die
debug ihre masten aufgestellt haben die
stromversorgung stattfindet also es ist
ja so viel unterwegs und so viele
infrastrukturen ähnliche maßnahmen dass
man eigentlich gar nicht daran denkt
aber wenn hier ein anschlag auf die
ölleitung stattfindet oder strom etc
der brandort um für solche szenarien
bestmöglich vorbereitet zu sein wird
auch die kooperation zwischen dem
bundesheer und dem blaulicht
organisationen immer wieder gehen
und hier haben wir gesehen wie eine
übung funktionieren kann
das muss man sich diese im ernstfall
vorstellen und sie hat alles
funktioniert glaube ich man muss sich
nur vorstellen was ist wenn das an drei
orten gleichzeitig passiert in
österreich dann wenn wir sehen wie es um
die gerätschaft des bundesheer ist in
wirklichkeit der politische
handlungsbedarf scheint gibt ein clown
lichtstreifen am horizont der politische
entscheidung und im september werde ein
vertrag unterzeichnen lassen für die
beschaffung von 150 neuen fahrzeugen